♪ [intro music] ♪
Give me one minute,
and I'll show you
how Security Command Center
can help you secure and manage risks
for your Google Cloud environment.
Security Command Center is a native
security and risk management platform
for Google Cloud
that helps continuously monitor
your Google Cloud environment,
gain visibility into Cloud assets,
discover vulnerabilities
and misconfigurations,
detect and respond to threats,
and demonstrate compliance space
on industry standards and benchmarks.
Security Command Center
allows to have centralized visibility
and control over your resources.
With Security Command Center
you can easily understand the resources
that are deployed and managed
and see which resources
have been added or removed.
Security Command Center
also allows you to identify
security misconfigurations
and compliance violations
in your Google Cloud assets,
and resolve them
by following actionable recommendations.
You can also uncover threats
targeting your resources using logs
and identify potential compromises
in containers.
Setting up Security Command Center
is very straightforward.
Just visit Google Cloud Console,
and under the Security section
is Security Command Center.
The pricing model is simple
and is based on the tier you choose.
There is a generous free Standard tier
that you can access through the Console,
and a paid Premium tier
that provides enterprise
security capabilities,
which you can access by contacting
the Google Cloud sales team.
Next time you're looking
to secure and manage risks
for your Google Cloud environment,
take a minute to look
at the Security Command Center.
To learn more, check out
cloud.google.com/security-command-center
♪ [outro music] ♪